mou ouais
qui est tu es comment as tu fait pour
trouver mon hôtel offs et johnatan je
faisais de l' escalade dans loin avec
vous quelques bonnes quand j'ai entendu
parler d'une forêt qui faisait trop
flipper et qui sera assez débile pour ne
pas explorer une forêt qui fait flipper
c'est là que je suis tombé sur une bande
de gamins bizarroïde en train de brûler
je me suis contenté de les suivre
jusqu'à cette incroyable château
combien taux toujours avec toi je suis
tout seul j'adore tailler la route en
solo comme ça je rencontre des gens
mortelle dans les auberges de jeunesse
et en parlant de mortels cette cape
sérieuse une vraie tuerie